>>Boris Smus: Hi, folks.
>>> Hey!
>>Boris Smus: All right.
Welcome to Point, Click, Tap, Touch, a session
about building multi-device web interfaces.
My name is Boris, and I'm a research engineer
working on user interfaces in the Google research
group.
>>Rick Byers: And I'm Rick.
I work on touchscreen support in Chrome and
I'm a member of the W3C standards groups working
on standardizing touchscreen support on the
web.
>>Boris Smus: So today's talk is mostly going
to be about input and we'll talk a bit about
mouse space input but the bulk of it is going
to be about touchscreens.
So just to motivate that, I'm sure you've
all got a touchscreen device, or maybe two,
or maybe three, now that you've got Pixels,
and so touch is becoming even more ubiquitous
than it was a year ago.
Mobile touch -- mobile use in general is projected
to overtake the desktop sometime early next
year, and the revenue forecast of touchscreen
modules only corroborate that.
You can see it's a very up-and-to-the-right
kind of graph.
Also we've got this new -- relatively new
form factor of touch laptops, of which the
Pixel is one, and also Windows -- Windows
machines are becoming increasingly touch-enabled.
Something like a quarter of Windows 8 laptop
sales have a touchscreen.
So if you're a developer working on the web,
you should expect your users to have a touchscreen
device increasingly.
And the good thing here is that the web has
a very powerful touch event API and it's been
around for something like five, six years
and has become standard over the last two
years or so, and the basics of this API is
we've got a touchstart event which fires when
your finger hits the screen, touchmove continually
fires as you're moving around, touchend and
touchcancel are two different ways of ending
that interaction.
So touchend is the natural thing that happens
when your finger is raised and touchcancel
happens if your finger was -- if your touch
gesture was cancelled for some other reason.
On Android, for example, if you start scrolling
an area, touchcancel will fire as the browser
begins to scroll.
So to distinguish between these multiple touches,
each one has a consistent identifier, and
this API that I'm describing works really
well across a number of devices.
Basically across the whole modern mobile browser
landscape.
So let me quickly show you how this looks.
On a Pixel, which is what I'm demoing from,
I've got this paint application.
You can see that as soon as I lower my fingers,
I can do this amazing finger-painting exercise.
And we support up to 10 points and you can
see each finger has a unique color which is
because they have unique IDs.
Now, if I didn't have a touchscreen, I could
emulate this behavior with just a mouse, and
you can see I can override this by turning
on emulate touch events in the Chrome developer
tools, and when I do that, I get this little
finger-like thing on the screen every time
I move the mouse.
And it's just a good reminder that says, "Hey,
there's a certain size to your finger," that
it's not as precise as your mouse.
And I'll talk more about that.
Now, of course because this is a standard
API, it works just as well across a variety
of devices, so here I've got the same exact
code running on a phone, and you can see that
the behavior of this application is the same.
Okay.
So I'll run through a couple of design suggestions,
because designing for touch is quite different
from designing for mouse and keyboard.
So the first tip here is obviously touch interfaces
require bigger targets.
Your finger is inherently far less precise
than a mouse, which can give you one- or two-pixel
precision, but exactly how big?
So extensive research has been done to suggest
that 9-by-9 millimeters is something like
the optimal touch target size, but the web
has a few things that complicate matters.
First, we've got a whole variety of devices
to support, and they vary hugely in their
device density, so DPI varies, and therefore
it's hard to map physical size to device pixels.
And secondly, the web has this concept of
CSS pixels not necessarily being the same
as device pixels because they're modified
by something called device Pixel ratio.
So with these two things in mind, we can do
some calculations for a variety of popular
devices.
Here we've got the Nexus line where we convert
9 millimeters into pixels and we can see what
that looks like on these devices.
On the Chromebook Pixel, it's something -- because
of further distance of interaction, you end
up with screwy -- with a slightly bigger -- with
fewer pixels required to represent the same
physical size.
So while we don't have like a clear guideline
in this case of what size you should use,
something between 42 and 58 pixels is our
recommendation.
And this is fairly consistent with other guidelines.
Second tip is related to hover.
So hover we can activate in two ways, generally
with a mouse-based interface, so with CSS,
using the colon hover pseudo-selector and
with JavaScript using mouseover and mouseout
events.
With touchscreens, generally, with some exceptions
like the Samsung S4 which has above-surface
hover, basically we don't have access to hover
state.
And even in the case of the S4, that hover
state is only in hardware and available in
Android.
It's not exposed to the web yet.
So what do we do in the case of -- in the
case of touch for hover?
Basically, here's an example of a hover test
page.
We've got two hover areas.
One of them has a link, the other does not.
And I can just activate hover by -- by tapping.
So a single tap activates hover on mobile
devices with touchscreens.
The problem is if you have a hover and a link
underlying that.
So in this case, if I click this area that
has a link, the hover state was triggered
but for so brief a time that the user didn't
actually get to see it.
So this happens a lot when you have menus,
hierarchical menus that are activated on hover,
and it's something to definitely avoid.
Okay.
The last designing kind of thing that I want
to talk about is the touch laptop form factor
and the kind of untapped potential that this
form factor can bring.
So there's two sort of axes here.
First, we can think about switching between
these two modalities of touch and not touch,
and it might look something like this.
So here's a gallery of photos.
In this case, I've got photos of celebrities.
You can see it's a very standard kind of interface
and I can pick new pictures with my mouse.
It's great.
So what happens if I want to use a touch device,
or my touchscreen in this case?
This is way too small for me to tap.
So you can see if -- as soon as I tap this
-- this page, I get this responsive input
effect and now everything is far more tappable.
So when I switch back to mouse, the page readjusts
back.
So this is an interesting concept that you
might want to explore.
Another possibility is to use both modes together.
So in this page, I have a map that I have
pointer-locked so whenever I pan around with
my trackpad or pinch zoom -- or sorry, two-finger
scroll, I can navigate the map.
And I can also place waypoints on this map
using my touchscreen.
So it's sort of an interesting interaction
using both -- both touch surfaces simultaneously.
And along the same veins, in this example
I have a small green rectangle that I can
move around as you'd expect, but I can also
simultaneously move my trackpad to rotate
it and with two fingers I'll create a scaling
effect.
And I can do these things simultaneously.
So it's kind of an interesting interaction
that's only possible with these two touch
surfaces simultaneously.
So with that, I'll hand over to Rick to talk
about some common problems and their solutions.
>>Rick Byers: So in getting the Pixel ready
to ship, we worked with a lot of different
web properties to help them make their Web
sites that were designed for desktop work
better with touch.
So what I want to go through here is some
of the common issues that we came across that
people hit regularly.
The first one is this code.
Does anyone realize off the bat what the problem
is with this code?
>> (Speaker is off microphone.)
>>Rick Byers: Right.
If you use it on a Pixel, you can't use the
trackpad.
And really this isn't about the Pixel.
This code was -- you know, the assumption
here is if I've got touch support, like in
particular the touch event APIs are supported
on this browser, then I must be on a mobile
device and I shouldn't listen to mouse events.
And this was actually never correct.
BlackBerry devices have a little trackball
that sends mouse events, so this would also
disable that.
But this is really bad for touchscreen laptops.
It means someone's got their laptop and they
upgrade to their spiffy new touchscreen laptop
and now a site that they're used to using
with their trackpad no longer works with the
trackpad.
Just because someone has a touchscreen on
their laptop doesn't mean they're going to
use it all the time.
In fact, a lot of users only use it for special
circumstances, like maps and whatnot, and
it really varies how much people use their
touchscreen on their laptop.
So you really don't want to disable mouse
support just because there's touch support.
Let me show you an example of that.
Not to pick on any particular site in particular,
but this page, this site, just to show you
how frustrating it is, I move my mouse over
these buttons and clearly I should be able
to click on these, but when I click, nothing
happens, and it's really frustrating and you
say, "Why the heck can't I click on this?"
Until you realize, "Oh, actually, I can tap
with touch."
And that's just because they've stopped listening
to the click event because it detects a touchscreen.
So don't do that.
So how do you -- what do you do instead?
So when you limit, don't try to predict whether
or not the user is going to do touch.
In the limit, you can't predict it.
For example, they might have a USB touchscreen
that's connected to a KVM switch, so it might
come and go during the lifetime of the page,
so you can't predict whether or not the user's
going to use touch.
Instead, what you should do is always listen
for touch events and mouse events and then
you can decide dynamically, when you see a
touch event get used, then you know the user
is using touch.
So in this case, we listened for both all
the time, and I think the main reason people
don't do this is for compatibility, touch
events by default, if I tap the screen, it
will send a series of mouse events to emulate
a mouse click, so all these Web sites that
were designed just for mouse will still work
by tapping the touchscreen.
And so I think the reason people stop listening
for mouse events is they want to avoid hitting
that redundant click event, but the right
way to do that is when you've consumed a touch
event is to call preventDefault on the event.
PreventDefault tells the browser "I've handled
this, please don't do something else with
it."
And this is generally what you want to do
anyway in most scenarios.
You know, if you're using touch to manipulate
an object, you don't want the browser to also
use that touch to pan the page, scroll the
page, for example.
So let me show you concretely what that looks
like.
This is a really simple application that just
registers an event handler on this blue box
here, so you can see if I move my mouse over,
it just lists the events that are fired.
So if I touch and drag, I get touchstart,
touchmove, and then -- oops -- if I touch
and drag, you can see I get touchmove and
then touchend.
But if I tap on this, you see I get touchstart,
touchend, as you'd expect, but then I also
get this compatibility mouse move -- mousedown,
mouseout click -- sequence that's emulated
in the click.
So to prevent that, I just go into my event
handler here and say ease out preventDefault,
just say "I've handled the event, please don't
do anything else with it."
And now when I tap I just get the touch events.
So if you leave here knowing -- remembering
nothing else, this is the most important thing:
Don't make your users suffer just because
they happen to have a touchscreen.
And now that you all have Pixels, this will
probably become pretty obvious to you.
Try it at your sites.
Now, you don't have to have a Pixel to test
this out.
So those of you watching the extended or on
YouTube that weren't as lucky to get a Pixel
yet, just go to Chrome flags and turn on enable
touch events.
We'd actually like to -- we'd actually like
Chrome to always support touch events and
the only reason we don't today is because
so many Web sites have this bug, but hopefully
at some point in the future we'll make this
the default mode.
So you should turn this on and test your Web
sites to make sure the mouse still works on
your Web sites with this on.
Another problem we see a lot is there's a
subtle difference in how the events are targeted,
so a lot of people will often in many scenarios
want to delegate to the same code for touch
and mouse, and there's a difference between
the mouse event model and the touch event
model in where the events go.
So as you probably know, with the mouse if
I move my mouse cursor over like this blue
rectangle here and press down and then drag
outside the rectangle, I'll get a mousedown,
some mouse moves, and a mouseout event targeted
at the rectangle, and then -- and then I'll
continue receiving events on whatever the
background element is, the white element in
this case.
It will get the mouseover, mousemoves, and
mouseup when I lift.
This isn't the same for touch.
For touch, the events always target the node
where the touch started, as opposed to the
node that's currently under the cursor as
for mouse.
So for touch, if I touch on this blue rectangle
and drag across and lift, the touch old events
are going to go to the rectangle, including
the end.
And this make a lot of sense for common scenarios.
I've got a slider that I'm manipulating with
touch.
You'd really rather not have to worry about
what happens if the user's finger falls off
the slider slightly as they're sliding it.
It make sense to say conceptually when the
user starts touching something, they're manipulating
that thing for the duration of their touch.
But this gets tricky if you think about what
if -- what if you have got a container with
some elements inside of it and it's changing
over time.
In particular, what if the element the user
touched on happens to get deleted while the
user's in the middle of their touch.
And this actually happened to me in some code
I was working on, and I was really surprised.
I didn't know what was going on.
What happens is we followed this model.
The events continue to go to the element where
you started touching.
Even if that element is no longer in the DOM,
that's where the events go.
They'll bubble up to the point that there's
no ancestor and they'll fall on the floor.
So if you've got an event handler on the container,
you're not going to get the events once the
inner node is removed, and that will look
to your app like a finger is just stuck down.
I've got a demo of that, so this is a really
simple app that just transforms this rectangle
to match with my touch events.
And this is -- this works fine because it's
just a simple rectangle.
But, you know, if this was a ticker or something
with some changing content inside of it or
a list of email or something, then it would
be more complicated.
So I'm going to simulate that by just adding
this red div every two seconds and then deleting
it and then adding a new one.
So if I happen to start touching on the red
div and drag around, as soon as the red div's
removed from the DOM, it's what's receiving
the events and so the container doesn't know
about the events anymore and it thinks my
finger is stuck down and now my code gets
confused.
If I try to touch it again, it's confused
because it missed the end.
It never got an end.
You see I got touchstart and I got another
touchstart, which is really confusing for
the code.
So to fix that, an easy way to fix it is to
just take my event handlers here, my move,
end, and cancel event handlers.
Really I don't want those on the container.
In this case, I want to take them -- instead
of putting them on the container, I can go
up here to my touchstart handler and I'll
put the event handlers instead on whatever
the target of the touchstart was.
So in this case, it's going to be -- if I
started touching on the red element, it's
going to be on the red element.
Now, in theory you might also want to go and
remove these event handlers and the end event
but actually it's not necessary because adding
the same event handler more than once is a
"no op."
So there's no disadvantage here to just adding
them and leaving them there.
So now you can see if I start touching this
red guy, now it's removed from the DOM.
It doesn't really exist anywhere except it's
being kept alive by the events that are being
sent to it, and so the JavaScript code can
still be fired and see those events even though
the node is not reachable in the DOM anywhere.
So that's how to fix that one.
Just like that.
Another common problem is dealing with small
targets.
Lots of the web is designed for a mouse today,
so the browser's got to do something to make
it easier for touchscreen users to hit small
things.
If we just relied on looking at the center
point of your finger, it would be way too
small.
As Boris said, you know, you ideally have
larger targets.
But if it's a site that's designed for a mouse
or if you want to try to strike some compromise
on your site where you don't want things to
be giant, then the browser's got to do something
to make it easier for people to touch large
-- touch small targets.
So what Chrome does, it's got a feature called
touch adjustment, and what it does, the green
rectangle here represents the bounding box
of my touch.
You know, using the radius from the hardware
on Pixel, we know the radius of the touch,
but if we don't know the radius on other hardware,
we can use a suitable default.
And then we look at all of the elements inside
that bounding box and we look at -- we'd find
every one that has some signal that it's activatable
by tapping somehow.
So it's got a click event handler or it's
got an active CSS pseudo-class.
Anything that we expect something will happen
when it's tapped.
And we score those based on how far away the
edge of that element is from the center of
the touch and how much of that element gets
overlapped by the touch.
And we pick the one with the highest score
and then we adjust the touch.
We don't change the raw touch events.
Touch events are a low-level API.
We don't want to muck with those.
But for the compatibility of most events,
we'll shift them.
We'll change what element is targeted and
we'll change the coordinates so that it actually
gets delivered to what we think the user is
trying to touch.
Let me show you that in a demo.
Oh, pro tip, by the way, for all of you with
your new Pixels.
Control shift plus.
We haven't put in the UI yet but we have a
nice UI restore feature.
You can zoom in and out the whole Chrome OS
UI.
So I'm going to do that for this demo and
show you -- well, let me just show -- if I
just tap here, I've got the rectangle showing
where my tap was, and the blue shows where
the click event went, and in this case, there's
nothing touchable underneath so there's nothing
unusual here.
And if I tap on top of a link, again, there's
nothing really unusual.
But if I tap on the boundary of a link like
this, you can see my touchend event, which
is the red dot, occurred on the "x" and "t"
in the word "text" here and down in the log
you can see the touchend event occurred on
this ID called "content," which is the text
content.
But I overlapped the link and so the browser
sees that overlap and it adjusts the click
event, so that the click is actually going
to the link, which is the blue dot next to
it.
And there's also two different signals that
we use so, you know, the link is the obvious
one but anything with a hover effect, like
right here, this text turns red when you hover
on top of it, so you can see I'm adjusting
down towards it.
Or something with a tab index, right?
A tab index indicates that you can focus it
by tapping -- by clicking on it or activating
it.
Or even just a mousedown event handler because
we fired those on tap as well.
These are all signals to tell us that something
is touchable.
And so this works great most of the time,
but it is possible to confuse it.
In particular, we need some signal that -- that
what you've got is designed to be activated
somehow, and if you're relying on event delegation,
so for example, you've got an event handler
on your entire document and then in JavaScript
you're deciding, oh, this event actually really
was on this element and I'm imperatively in
JavaScript going to rewrite the event to the
right element, that gives the browsers no
real signal of -- of where -- what is touchable
and what isn't.
Not only is that going to disable touch adjustment,
but if there's other signals like hover effect
and active effects, it might actually make
touch adjustment behave worse than not having
it at all.
My favorite example of this is Gmail, unfortunately.
And we will get this fixed at some point soon.
Oops.
Let me go back here.
So I can tap these stars and activate them,
no problem.
And that's because the star in its unactive
state has a hover effect that makes it look
slightly different when you hover over it.
So it looks tappable to us.
Every time I touch near it, it will adjust
towards it.
If I try to tap to turn off the star, it is
incredibly frustrating.
I just keep hitting the things next to it.
That's because these other things on either
side of it appear to us to be tappable, but
there is no longer any signal on the star
telling us that it is tappable.
Gmail is using event delegations, so there
is no event handler on it and there is no
longer a hover effect or anything to tell
us it is random background content.
And so we don't think it is something the
user is trying to touch.
Another question I get a lot is how should
you recognize more complex gestures like pinch
or rotate.
Mobile Safari has a proprietary API for this
called gestureevent.
And IE10 has a proprietary API for this called
MSGestureevent.
So in Chrome, we are not going to add another
proprietary gesture API.
We think proprietary APIs are bad for the
Web.
We would love to have a standardized API that
works across all browsers.
[ Applause ]
That's the first time I got a applause for
not doing a feature.
I love it.
We love to have a standard API that all browsers
can implement.
But for various reasons, that's not going
to happen any time soon.
So -- but the good news is, you actually don't
need the browser to do this for you.
This is something that can be done perfectly
well by libraries, built on top of the touch
events.
There is a wide variety of different libraries.
And then you can use one of these libraries
and have it work across all these browsers,
not have to worry about the differences in
the browsers.
So I wrote a little demo here using hammer.js
which exposes a whole slew of different types
of gestures.
But the transform gesture in particular recognizes
pinch and rotate.
Let me just show you what this looks like.
So with a very small amount of code, I can
handle moving this box around, pinching it
to zoom it, and rotating it.
I haven't had to listen to touch events at
all.
I have just done this and listened for transformer
events and imported the hammer library.
So if you want to do it with gestures, I encourage
you to explore these libraries and contribute
to them.
Most of them I believe are open source projects.
Much better than a proprietary browser API
in my opinion.
And now back to Boris to talk about performance.
>>Boris Smus: All right.
So, one performance issue you may have seen
are heard of is this infamous click delay.
So the idea here is the clicks on mobile browsers
are generally delayed by something like 300
milliseconds because the browser needs to
decide if your click was a genuine click or
if it was actually a double tap.
So there is this gesture where you want to
zoom into some content that's very small and
you double tapped that and the browser zooms
in.
And so This behavior can cause pages to feel
very slow and unresponsive.
And if you have been working in this space,
you have probably heard of fastclick as a
solution for this.
What fastclick basically does is instead of
using click, it uses just the touchend event,
which is something we described earlier.
So, of course, you know now that there's some
drawbacks to using touchend versus click such
as the touchfuzzing that Rick described earlier.
And you lose that if you use a fastclick library.
In cases where we don't need a fastclick library,
we should avoid it.
A couple things also changed over the last
year or os in Chrome.
Firstly, Chrome desktop, which has touch support
in some cases, like in this Pixel or on Windows
devices, there's no click delay because we
don't actually support the double tap to zoom
gesture.
>>Rick Byers: That's another feature, by the
way, we are never going to support because
we are not going to add 300 milliseconds to
the click events.
>>Boris Smus: Excellent.
>>Rick Byers: If I have anything to say about
it.
Sorry.
>>Boris Smus: In Chrome for Android, we have
an optimization that landed over the last
year that doesn't create a click delay in
the case of a fixed viewport.
So you can fix your viewport with user scalable
equals no.
And in that case, again, the double tap gesture
doesn't exist.
So there is no need for us to delay.
So it is important that the fastclick library
that you use is aware of these changes.
Otherwise, you lose the benefits.
So we worked with FT Labs, which support one
of the most popular fastclick libraries.
And they've patched their code to make sure
that their library is smart about this.
So keep that in mind next time you're using
a fastclick approach.
Okay.
Another performance issue, you may have written
or seen code that looks like this.
So this code essentially just renders every
time you get a touchmove event.
The problem with this is that touchmove can
fire very quickly.
Often it fires much faster than your render
loop, which is 60 hertz if you're getting
a smooth performance -- smooth visual display.
In some browsers, this problem is mitigated
by coalescing multiple touch events into one.
So there's touch arrays that come with every
touch event.
And it is up to the browser, basically, to
decide if it should put all the events together
or if it should create separate touchmove
events.
So let me just quickly show you here on a
mobile device the possible issue.
So here I've got some code that basically
does this naive approach where it renders
everything on touch.
You can see I have got one finger.
I'm just drawing the point and that works
really well.
I can add a second finger and a third finger.
You can sort of see the slowdown now.
But as I add the fourth finger, things really
degrade.
>>> Ahhh.
>>Boris Smus: So this is not what we want.
[ Laughter ]
So touch events are piling up and, basically,
we're not able to render quickly enough and
there is a big backlog of touches which is
why you see this delay.
So the solution to this is to avoid expense
operations in your touch handlers.
In general, this is good practice.
But this is especially important for touch.
So rather than rendering, you can store the
touches and then set up a separate animation
loop with something like requestAnimationframe
which makes sure that every single render
is tied to the vsync of your display.
Just by doing this small optimization, let
me show you the difference.
So I will switch to the requestAnimationframe
version.
There we go.
And you can see that same four-finger gesture
is now extremely responsive just with that
one small change.
Okay.
Another performance issue is related to scroll
jank.
So in case you are not familiar with scroll
jank, the basic idea is sometimes scrolling
can be very uneven and just not be very responsive
to your actual input.
This can come in many forms.
But we've done some studies, and it's very
important for engagement.
So if your users are dealing with a janky
site, it's likely that they won't come back.
And Chrome team has spent a lot of effort
of trying to optimize this scrolling.
And the big push has been to move scrolling
to a separate hardware-accelerated GPU thread.
Event handling, though, is still, of course,
on the main thread.
So there's something that can happen if you
have fairly busy main thread because every
time you scroll, as Rick pointed out earlier,
you can prevent the default behavior of the
scroll.
And the way we do that is in JavaScript by
using event prevent default.
What happens is every time you scroll, we
need to call back -- well, Chrome calls back
into the main thread to see if it is allowed
to.
And if the main thread is really busy, that
causes the GPU thread to wait.
So here's how this looks.
I have got an artificially busy main thread
in this page.
And I have also enabled an empty touchmove
handler.
So it just it looks like this.
It is a no op.
And if you see me scrolling here, my finger
is moving smoothly, it's very janky.
So by simply turning this off, I have a very
different experience.
And that's a no op touch handler.
So what's the story here?
How can we avoid this?
Well, first, and quite obviously, we can just
not use that touch event handler.
If it is unnecessary, there's no need for
you to put it there and you will save -- you
will save yourself from seeing this issue
at all.
And, of course, remember that in some cases,
it's not so bad to have -- to rely on synthesized
DOM events like click, scroll, and context
menu which all fire on touch devices.
So, basically, what I'm saying is, you don't
need to implement touch-specific event handlers
necessarily to have a good experience on touchscreens.
And another approach to solving this problem
is if you definitely do need a touch handler,
make sure you've contained that touch region
to be as small as possible.
So Chrome has optimizations that says if the
part of the page that the user is scrolling
doesn't have a touch handler, then there is
no need for us to call back to the main thread.
And we can just do the thing very quickly.
So, essentially, if you think of your page
-- if you think of subdividing your page into
regions, you can decide whether or not you
want to optimize for smooth scrolling or for
touch event handling.
So this example that I showed you earlier
is the worst case where you've got a touch
handler on your whole body for not good reason.
Okay.
Back to Rick.
>>Rick Byers: So we told you a bit about the
state of touch on the Web today.
I want to touch briefly on some of the directions
that we want to head going forward.
So, first of all, here's just a rough idea
of some of the goals that we've got.
First of all, as we talked before, touch events
are pretty low-level API.
And a lot of times you want to express your
intent in a higher-level fashion.
So we would like to do more to eliminate the
need for you to drop down to this low-level
API.
For example, a really common scenario is to
want to support dragging things around, right,
drag and drop-type UIs.
There is actually a high-level drag and drop
API for the Web today.
Unfortunately, it is only implemented from
mouse.
Every browser that's drag and drop only does
it with mouse input, which seems a real shame.
So we are starting to experiment with this
in Chrome OS.
You can try it on your Pixel.
You can turn it on in "about" flags.
It is touch-based drag and drop.
Long press will initiate a drag and drop.
And we are hoping we will get that on by default
in M29, which is coming up in a little bit.
And then once we're happy with it there, we
will turn it on in the other platforms as
well, Android and Windows.
We also want to give you more control over
the browser's default behavior so you don't
have to fall back to touch events.
A really common scenario with touch events
is an image carousel where you want to support
swiping between the different images.
And really that's just a scrollable div except
that you really want to snap where it stops
to image boundaries.
And so what people end up doing is they use
a library or they write custom code to listen
for touch events and then they have to implement
all the scrolling themselves, which doesn't
sound that bad until you realize that there
is a certain physics that people are used
to and they are used to a certain momentum
when you fling and then trying to match that
to the browser's behavior which is changing
in between browsers is very hard.
And then this whole -- all the work we do
to try to do to scroll on a GPU thread so
we're not subject to jank for the main thread,
all that goes out the window when you implement
scrolling in JavaScript.
So we love for common scrolling scenarios
like that.
We would like to just give you features that
let you customize the behavior like add snap
points.
IE10 has a feature for this, so we are talking
with Microsoft about how we can standardize
that and bring it to the standard Web.
And we're working with other browser vendors
to bring new Web standards to help with touch
as well.
So, in particular, IE10 has a number of touch
features that are pretty nice.
So we're talking with Microsoft about those.
In particular, pointer events is a new input
model in IE10.
IE10 doesn't support the touch event model
that we have been talking throughout this
slide for.
They have got a different input model called
pointer events.
It has some design properties that we are
pretty excited about.
First of all, it abstracts different types
of input.
You still need to think to think about touch
and mouse separately when you are designing
your site.
Sometimes the right thing to do is to handle
them the same.
If the right thing to do is to handle touch
and mouse the same, you should be able to
use the same code to do it.
This model extends the mouse even model, which
means if you have already got a big investment
in code that's designed for the mouse model,
you can -- rather than having to worry about
things like the difference in targeting model
and the lack of over-and-out events, you can
update that code to work with point events
very easily.
We would love to see more discussion on pointer
events.
This is the mailing list for the standards
group.
Love to hear discussion there.
The implementation, obviously, IE has implementation
and Firefox has said they have started to
work on an implementation.
Microsoft built a prototype for Chrome, which
is great.
And now we have just announced that we're
going to start landing some experimental support
in Blink for pointer events.
But adding a new input model isn't something
we take lightly especially when it is redundant
with existing models and not necessarily something
that browser vendors are going to embrace.
We are starting by adding some features that
are going to make it easy to build high-performance,
high-quality polyfills for pointer events.
And then we really want to get feedback from
you guys.
We want to see if you vote with your feet
by using the polyfills and send us signals
that you really want this model natively in
the browser, then we will add it to Chrome.
So today there is a few early polyfills.
None of them are perfect, Butt hey are all
pretty good and a good way to get a handle
on how pointer events work.
If you went to the Web components talk earlier,
the application of Web components, the polymer
framework, they decided that pointer events
was the right input model for polymer.
So they built a polyfill that emulates pointer
events that you can use completely independently.
So please check those out and send us feedback.
I will not go into full details of the pointer
events API.
Microsoft has a bunch of good links.
There's lots of full talks on their own.
I want to touch on two things I'm particularly
excited about.
First of all, I said that you can -- they
let you specify declaratively what to do with
touch.
And this is done through a CSS property called
touch action.
When you say touch action none, it means you
don't want the browser to take a default action
on touch, like scrolling.
And instead you just want to deliver events.
Where if you say touch action auto, then that
means you want the browser to determine what
to do.
So, for example, as soon as you start scrolling,
the browser says I'm supposed to scroll now
and it can start scrolling immediately and
just send a cancel event to JavaScript to
say you will not get any more events now that
these started scrolling.
And it doesn't have to block on the main thread.
So that scroll jank problem that Boris showed
which can be a real problem especially on
mobile devices just goes away completely with
this.
I also said that this can be better for code
sharing.
We want to enable you to build sites that
work well across a range of devices.
And so let me show you an example here.
This is a really simple demo of -- this is
a really simple demo of drag and drop that's
kind of modeled after the Google+ circle editor.
The idea is I can touch on a card and drag
it -- let me get all three of the circles
-- touch on a card and drag it to one of these
circles.
This is designed to work with multiple inputs.
I can touch two cards at once, or I can even
use a mouse and touchscreen at once to drag
things around.
And so let me show you what was involved to
make this work.
There's a bit of code here.
I won't go through all of it.
The move handlers perhaps is the most interesting.
When the mouse moves, I just have a little
bit of work to do really and then I delegate
to this common move function.
But when I get a touchmove event, I am going
to delegate to the common move function.
But then I have got to do a lot of other stuff
to compensate for the difference in targeting
model.
This is all specific to the touchmodel.
And then the common function for handling
movements is, like, a couple of lines.
It is unfortunate, this is the only thing
I can do in common.
The start and end events are like that as
well.
It is a pretty small amount of common code
for the two cases.
If I use pointer events, I can get the amount
of shared code for about half the lines of
code being shared for the two scenarios up
to 97% in this case.
And get the number of lines of code I had
to write down from 131 down to 89.
Let me show you what that looks like.
In this case, since Chrome here doesn't have
pointer event support, I'm using the points.js
polyfill.
So with much less code, now I can still support
dragging things around with touch and a mouse
simultaneously.
And you can see that there is very little
code here that to handle the difference between
mouse events and pointer events.
I basically just have to check to see if the
browser supports pointer events.
If so, I will use events that start with the
word "pointer" instead of the word "mouse."
Otherwise, the events are the same.
And in order to handle multiple things moving
around at once, if I'm using pointer events,
I'm using the unique identifier for pointer.
Otherwise, if I am using mouse events, I will
just use this constant one.
And, otherwise, all the code is the same.
The move event handler is just this here.
And then I have over-and-out handlers.
And so for this scenario where I really want
the same thing to happen regardless the type
of input, I can dramatically reduce the amount
of code I have to write and have to test,
which is a big part of it.
That's a big part of it.
So those are the reasons that I'm exciting
about pointer events.
We would love to get your feedback, start
using the polyfills.
And, hopefully, we will see it in Chrome at
some point in the future.
That's it for the future.
And we have given you a few tips now for how
to make your site work great on touch.
Now that you all have Pixels, please try out
your Web sites and apply these tips and make
your sites awesome on touchscreen laptops.
If you have any problems doing that, we want
to hear about them.
This is an area of the Web we are trying to
make better and make more consistent across
different form factors and different browsers.
So, please, we want to hear about it.
The public Web events mailing list, this the
group of the W3C that I'm a member of that
works on touch events.
That's a great mailing list to give us feedback
on the touch event model.
You can also reach out to me directly on Google+
or Twitter.
And Boris and I are going to be to available
to take questions.
We have got, like, one minute, I guess.
Why don't we take one question from our extended
audience.
We have got thousands of people watching around
the world and take one quick question.
Please submit feedback using this URL, and
then we will be down here to take any live
questions.
You got the Dory up?
Do we have any?
>>Boris Smus: Maybe a live question, how's
that?
We'll take one.
>>Rick Byers: One live question.
Okay.
>>> Do you know we're awesome?
>>Rick Byers: We do now.
Thank you very much.
>>Boris Smus: Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>> You were talking at the beginning about
the hover.
I was wondering if there is any standards
work going on of sort of creating an alternative
to hover when you do the touchdown, that that
activates another style and touchup?
Instead of hover, you know, have that in the
CSS rather than having to do that in JavaScript?
>>Rick Byers: Right.
That's what the active CSS pseudoclass is
for.
The active CSS pseudoclass is defined in the
standard to say when the user is actively
manipulating this thing, then active should
be applied.
So we apply that -- on touchdown, we apply
that and we stop applying on touchup.
There is a couple of details.
We don't want to apply when you are scrolling,
so there is a slight delay before it kicks
in.
But that's effectively exactly what active
is for.
>>> Does that work in multiple -- does that
work in other browsers?
>>Rick Byers: It works in many.
I think there is a caveat with iOS that I'm
not too familiar with.
But I think there is some detail where you
have to do something extra to make sure it
works in iOS.
Certainly in Chrome, it works fine.
(Speaker off microphone.)
>>Rick Byers: Depends upon your layout.
It can be made to work.
>>> I seem to recall having tried that and
it didn't work.
>>Rick Byers: Certainly, that's an example
of something we don't want you to have a touchevent
handler to just change the style when something
is being touched like depressing a button.
>>> Thanks.
>>Rick Byers: All right.
Thanks very much.
We will be down here for questions and then
up in the Chrome office hours area.